COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER A
GOOD AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE THE
COVE IN NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
IN THE HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING. IN FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES AND COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE
HAS MADE. THE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE. THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARING
TODAY IN THE CAPITAL IN THE
SENATE CHAMBERS. IN A AND I
BELIEVE THERE ARE NO SENATORS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY TODAY.
TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS
WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO
THE EXTENT THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS. ALLOW
IT WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS. WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE. IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEES WEBSITE IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE. SIX
THREE SIX FOUR THE ACCESS CODE
IS. EIGHT SEVEN SIX EIGHT NINE
FOUR ONE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE.
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION. PRESS THIS ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A
LINE NUMBER. THIS CAN BE DONE.
THIS THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT.
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATE RECALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER. THAT TIME YOU WILL
BE ON MUTE IT AND YOU'LL BE
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
AS NOTE. THAT IN ORDER FOR US
TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MUTE. THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING OR HEARING THE HEARING
THE- HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
CONDUCTED HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE
TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE.
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL OF
PATIENTS SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. ALL RIGHT
NOW FIRST- I BELIEVE WE NEED TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM- LET'S SEE.
BUT DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS- THE COMMITTEE CHAIR
THAT'S ME MAY IS A TWO TIME
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY EACH SIDE
WILL BE PERMITTED EQUALAMOUNT
OF TIME WHICH IS TO WITNESSES
TWO MINUTES EACH ALL THOSE
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON
MEASURES. TO MAKE IT CLEAR UP
FRONT THAT I WILL PERMIT EACH
SIDE SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION TO
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES EACH
PRIMARY WITNESS WILL BE PITTED
AGAINST TESTIFIED FOR TWO
MINUTES. I WILL THEN
ADDITIONALLY PERMIT EACH SIDE
OF A MAX OF TWENTY MINUTES FOR
WITNESSES WHO MUST. LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO NAME AFFILIATION
AND POSITION. ALL RIGHT LET'S
ESTABLISH QUORUM MADAM CHIEF
COUNSEL WOULD YOU CALL THE
ROLL. PLEASE SENATORS TURN YOUR
MICROPHONES ON ON ESTABLISHING
A QUORUM UMBERG HERE. AMBERG
HERE BARGES. BARGES PRESIDENT
OF THE MIDDLE. ABIERTO HERE DID
US ALL YEAR DID ALSO HEAR
GONZALEZ HERE GONZALEZ HERE
HERTZBERG. JONES HERE JONES
HERE LAYERED HERE LAYERED HERE
STERN. WHY CAL SKI HERE WHAT
KASKY HERE WIENER. YOU HAVE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM THANK YOU
MADAM CHIEF COUNSEL- WE HAVE
SIX BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA FOR
WHICH ON CONSENT. THE ITEMS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ARE AS
FOLLOWS FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE SB
THREE FIVE FIVE BY SENDER
BECKER WITH AMENDMENTS FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO S. B. TWO EIGHT
EIGHT BY ENATOR JONES FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE S. B. FIVE
SEVEN EIGHT ALSO BY SENATOR
JONES. AND FINALLY FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR S. B. FIFTY THREE
BY SENATOR LEYVA- IS THERE MOST
OF THE CONSENT CALENDAR. CENTER
LAYERED MOVES ALL RIGHT- BEN
SECRETARY IF YOU CALL THE ROLL
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS
ONE TWO THREE AND FOUR- BERG HI
pI'M BURKE BY BURGESS. CAN YOU
GET ON A MICROPHONE PLEASE
SORRY- HORSES. FORGES HI WE'RE
JUST LIKE EVERY IT'LL- BUT IN
STATE CAPITOL. THE RUSSELL I
THE RUSSELL HI IT ALSO HI
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ HI
HERTZBERG. JONES HI JONES- A
LAYERED BY LAYERED I STERN. BY
CAL SKI. HI WHY CASKEY I WIENER.
YOU HAVE ONE TWO THREE FOUR
FIVE SIX SEVEN YOU HAVE SEVEN
TWO ZERO YOU WANT ME TO GO
THROUGH ONE MORE TIME- LET'S
SEE CYNICAL YET YES IF YOU CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. HAVE A AT
ALL. ZERO I HERTZBERG STERN
WIENER RIGHT NOT A UNILATERAL
OKAY LET'S LET'S WILL PUT THOSE
ON CALL CONGRATULATIONS TO
SENATOR JONES WHOSE BILLS
COMPRISE 50% OF THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. OF ALL RIGHT. NOW
MOVING ON. TO TODAY'S OTHER
BUSINESS- CENTAMIN HAS BEEN
WAITING WAITING PATIENTLY-
CENTER YOU MAY PRESENT SENATE
RESOLUTION. TWELVE WHAT ONE
SECOND SENTIMENTAL TAKE YOUR
MICROPHONE IS ON WHAT DO I DO
TO I WAS ON A HIGH THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE. ON BEHALF OF THE API
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS ALONG WITH
DR PAN I'M PRESENTING SR
TWELVE. A RESOLUTION CONDEMNING
THE HATE THAT THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER COMMUNITY HAS FACED IN
LIGHT OF THIS PANDEMIC. AND
ASKING FOR SUPPORT FROM THIS
BODY THE STATE SENATE. OF
COURSE API HE IS NOT NEW TO
AMERICA OR EVEN CALIFORNIA. BUT
AS BOLD AS THE HISTORY OF ASIAN
IMMIGRATION ITSELF. LONG AGO
ASIAN AMERICANS WERE SUBJECTED
TO THE YELLOW PERIL RHETORIC OF
THE NINETEENTH CENTURY. WHICH
WAS ACCOMPANIED BY A WIDE ARRAY
OF HATEFUL AND VIOLENT ACTS.
API'S ALSO SUBJECTED TO GROSSLY
DISCRIMINATORY LAWS. AT THE
LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL LEVELS.
IN FACT WELL IN THE TWO CENTS
OVER A CENTURY THE IN FIFTEENTH
THAT PLAN. OR ADOPT. I SPENT WE
PUT EACH RIGHTS OF ALL WHO WERE
BOTH HERE IN THIS COUNTRY
REGARDLESS OF RACE. ASIAN WERE
FOR EMIGRATING TO THIS COUNTRY.
AND THOSE ALREADY HERE ONE ON
TO COME CITIZENS VOTE. SERVE
INJURIES OR MANY STATES EVEN
PURCHASE PROPERTY. JUST A FEW
WEEKS AGO WE MARKED THE SEVENTY
NINTH ANNIVERSARY OF PRESIDENT
ROOSEVELT'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
NINETY SIXTY SIX. WHICH
AUTHORIZED INTERNMENT OF
JAPANESE AMERICANS. THIS WAS
ONE OF THE MOST SHAMEFUL
ACTIONS OF THE ROOSEVELT
ADMINISTRATION AND A STAIN ON
OUR COUNTRY'S HISTORY. AND IT
WAS NOT UNTIL NINETEEN SIXTY
FIVE THE RESTRICTIONS ON ASIAN
IMMIGRATION WERE LIFTED. MY
PARENTS LIKE MANY ASIAN
IMMIGRANTS WERE PART OF THAT
FIRST POST NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE
WE'VE IN GRAYSON. BUT THAT WAS
THEN AND THIS IS NOW RIGHT. WE
LIVE IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE TODAY
ASIAN AMERICANS AND PACIFIC
ISLANDERS ARE LEADERS AND
BUSINESS LABOR FINANCE
ENTERTAINMENT TECHNOLOGY
ACADEMIA AND POLITICS. WE
CELEBRATED THE ELECTION OF
COMELEC HARRIS AS THE FIRST
ASIAN AMERICAN TO THE WHITE
HOUSE. WE SAW THE FIRST ASIAN
MOVIE BEEN ARE ARE NOT MINORITY.
I'M SORRY I'M BLANKING ON THE
NAME OF AT THE MOMENT BE WIN
BEST PICTURE LAST YEAR ANOTHER
AMERICAN MOVIE ABOUT ASIAN
AMERICANS AND IMMIGRATION. GET
NOMINATED FOR BEST PICTURE THIS
YEAR. BUT DESPITE ALL THESE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS FOR ASIAN
AMERICANS NOW IS A TIME OF
INCREDIBLE UNCERTAINTY AND
FEAR. AND THAT IS WHY THIS
RESOLUTION IS SO IMPORTANT. IN
RECENT YEARS WE'VE SEEN THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST MOST OF
AMERICANS. WITH THE TRAVEL BAN
THE CAPTAIN WAS A PART.
THREATEN TO REVOKE THE
BIRTHRIGHT CITIZENSHIP THAT
GUARANTEES SO MANY API'S ARE
BASIC RIGHTS IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND SCAPEGOAT ASIAN AMERICANS
IN THE NAME OF THE CLASS
BECAUSE OF THE COLD NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. UNSURPRISING API'S
ARE NOW IN THE MIDST OF AN
ALARMING SURGE OF ANTI API HATE
CRIMES. ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
USING VIOLENT ACTION OTHER
OUTRAGEOUS INCIDENTS OF RACISM
DIRECTED AGAINST API'S.
INCLUDING MANY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. IN JANUARY EIGHTY
FOUR YEAR OLD V. CHAU RUSSIA
NOT POPPY A GENTLE AND NEARLY
BLIND ELDERLY KIND MAN. WHICH
PUSHED HIS DEATH WHILE WALKING
IN SAN FRANCISCO. THE NEXT DATE
JANUARY THIRTY FIRST THREE
ELDERLY APRS WORST SALTED IN
OAKLAND CHINATOWN DISTRICT.
INCLUDING ONE ELDERLY MAN WHO
SUFFERED SEVERE INJURIES. IN MY
HOME DISTRICT IN ORANGE COUNTY
MADE SEEN VIRAL VIDEOS OF API
WOMEN BEING SCREAMED AT CALLED
THE TRYING TO BURST AND TOLD TO
GO BACK TO ASIA. ARE YOU MAY
HAVE READ ABOUT THE C. FAMILY A
CHINESE AMERICAN FAMILY THAT'S
BEEN SUBJECTED TO FIVE MONTHS.
OF LATE NIGHT HARASSMENT AT
THEIR NEW HOME IN LADERA RANCH.
ACCORDING TO THE PEW RESEARCH
CENTER ABOUT 31% OF ASIAN
AMERICANS HAVE SUFFERED SOME
KIND OF DISCRIMINATION OR HATE
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE CALL
THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AND
ACCORDING TO A NEW REPORT
RELEASED TODAY BY STOCK API
HATE. NEARLY THIRTY EIGHT
HUNDRED HATE INCIDENTS HAVE
BEEN REPORTED AGAINST ASIAN
AMERICANS SINCE THE START OF A
PANDEMIC. API'S ARE BEING
ACCOSTED HARASSED COUGHED ON
SPIT ON ASSAULTED AND MURDERED.
WE'RE FRUSTRATED WE'RE SCARED
OR ANGRY AND MANY EIGHT PIECE
OF PRICE FRANKLY DO NOT FEEL
WELCOME IN THIS COUNTRY WE CALL
HOME. AND WE'RE TIRED OF BEING
ALONE IN THIS FIGHT. WE'RE
TIRED OF BEING INVISIBLE. WE
WANT TO BE SEEN AND HEARD AND
WE NEED YOUR VOICES THE VOICES
OF THE STATE LEGISLATURE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA TO STAND WITH US
LOUDLY AND FIRMLY. AND TELL US
YOU ARE WELCOME INTERFERE AND
WE HAVE YOUR BACK. BECAUSE OF
ASIAN AMERICANS DON'T FEEL
WELCOME AND SAFE HERE IN
CALIFRNIA. THE CONNELL STATE
WITH THE HIGHEST NUMBER AND
HIGHEST PERCENTAGE OF API'S.
THEN WHERE CAN WE FEEL SAFE AND
AFFIRMED. NOW LET'S BE CLEAR
API'S ARE NOT THE ONLY
COMMUNITY THAT EXPERIENCE
RACISM AND HATE GROUPS IN
RECENT YEARS. THE ALARMING RISE
OF WHITE NATIONALISM HAS
COINCIDED WITH THE CONCOMITANT
INCREASE IN HATE DRIVEN ATTACKS
ON A NUMBER OF MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES. WE SING MUSLIMS
JEWS LGBTQ COMMUNITY AFRICAN
AMERICANS LATINOS AND MANY
OTHERS TARGETED IN RECENT YEARS.
I'M SO DEEPLY GRATEFUL TO THE
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS
LATINO LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS THE
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS AND
THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
FOR FORMALLY EXPRESSING THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THE API COMMUNITY.
THIS SOLIDARITY IS SO IMPORTANT
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT WE
OUTNUMBER THEM. THOSE OF US WHO
BELIEVE IN LOVE. BELIEVE IN
UNITY BELIEVE AND PRAY
SILVERCITY OUTNUMBERTHOSE OF
THAT'S WHO BELIEVE IN HATE AND
DIVISION AND RACISM. AND THAT
IS WHY I HAVE TO SAY I AM
DISAPPOINTED IN THIS BODY AND
WHAT I SEE IS THE UNACCEPTABLE
DELAYS IN GETTING THIS
RESOLUTION PASSED. THIS
RESOLUTION WITH AN INDUCED
EXACTLY ONE MONTH AGO TODAY. AN
IDENTICAL RESOLUTION HR TWENTY
THREE WAS PASSED OUT OF THE
ASSEMBLY WITHIN A COUPLE DAYS.
S. UNANIMOUSLY OUT OF COMMITTEE
ENJOYED BROAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT INCLUDING BEING CO
AUTHORED BY THE ASSEMBLY'S
MINORITY LEADER. I AM NEW TO
THIS BODY BUT I DO NOT
UNDERSTAND WHY A RESOLUTION TO
CONDEMN ANTI ASIAN HATE AT THIS
TIME WHEN YOUR CONSTITUENTS ARE
HURTING HAS BEEN SO DELAYED. WE
ARE BEING TARGETED FOR ASKING
FOR SOLIDARITY WERE ASKING FOR
SUPPORT AND WE HAVE NOT
RECEIVED A FROM THIS BODY WE
ASK YOU TO BE AS ANGRY ABOUT
THE HATE CRIMES THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING. AS WE ARE. SO I
WANT TO INTRODUCE WITH THAT
TESTIFYING MONTY SAID POKORNY.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE ASIAN
PACIFIC POLICY AND PLANNING
COUNCIL. THANK YOU MR. THANK
YOU SENATOR MEN- AND- MANUTIUS
COOK CARNEY ARE YOU- CURRENTLY
ON THE PS. ALL RIGHT AND I AM
CAN YOU HEAR ME THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MANISH
UNCLE GURNEY AND I'M EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE ASIA PACIFIC
POLICY AND PLANNING COUNCIL WE
ARE A COALITION OF OVER FORTY
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT SERVE AND REPRESENTS A ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION API THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY ADDITIONALLY I
SERVE AS CO FOUNDER STOP áP I
HATE SINCE MARCH NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHTH AVE YEAH I
HATE AND BEEN COLLECTING DATA.
ON HATE INCIDENTS AGAINST ASIAN
AMERICANS IN THE UNITED STATES
BETWEEN MARCH TWENTY TWENTY AND
FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE STOP
AB HATE AS RECEIVED ALMOST
THIRTY EIGHT HUNDRED INCIDENTS
FROM ACROSS ALL FIFTY STATES
AND THE DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA.
THAT INCLUDES. WHAT ONE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED NINETY ONE
FROM CALIFORNIA A WOUND OR 44%
OF ALL INCIDENTS THESE INCLUDE
VERBAL HARASSMENT
DISCRIMINATION IN THE WORKPLACE
HOUSING AND PUBLIC
ACCOMMODATIONS AND ALSO
PHYSICAL OF PAUL. ANYTHING
SENATORS MAN AND SENATORS PAN
AM THE API LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS
FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE AS R. TWELVE IS STILL
CRITICAL TO MAKING CLEAR THAT
WE DO NOT TOLERATE HATE IN
CALIFORNIA. IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE MAKE THIS ABUNDANTLY
CLEAR TO ALL OF THOSE IN OUR
STATE AND TO THE SIGNALING AN
API IN CALIFORNIA. AND FOR THAT
REASON I AM HERE TO URGE TODAY
IT'S PASSAGE GIVEN WHAT HAS
HAPPENED THIS IS THE FIRST MOST
IMPORTANT DATA IN- MAKING CLEAR
TO ALL OF YOU KNOW THE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WE DO NOT ABIDE
BY HEY. AND THAT WE SUPPORT
ASIAN AMERICAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITY THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO TESTIFY TODAY.
THANK YOU MISCONDUCT. ALL
RIGHT- LET'S NOW TURN TO
WITNESSES HERE IN THE CHAMBER I
SEE NONE- WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. WE COULD SEE ROOM ONE
TWELVE IF THERE ANY WITNESSES
THERE ARE NONE- WILL NEXT TURN
TO THE PHONE LINES. INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF S. R. TWELVE SHOULD- DIAL
IN- AS I MENTIONED BEFORE. WILL
WILL- PERMIT WITNESSES DIALING
IN TO STATE THEIR NAME THEIR
ORGANIZATION AND THEIR
POSITION- MISTER MODERATOR IF
YOU COULD OPEN THE PHONE LINES
AND GIVE US AN ESTIMATE IS THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
WAITING ON LINE. YES THANK YOU
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW.
AND WE HAVE ONE IN Q. AND
THAT'LL CONFIRM LINE OF TWENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER ON
BEHALF OF THIS IS THE RIGHT
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT WE
APOLOGIZE FOR MISSING THE
DEBTOR- THE WATER DEADLINE
THANK YOU. GIVE MADAME
MODERATOR ANYONE ELSE. ONLINE
IN SUPPORT THERE IS NOBODY ELSE
AND- ALL RIGHT IF IT WEREN'T
FOR YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. ALL
RIGHT- WELCOME BACK NO ONE IN
SUPPORT ALL RIGHT- OPPOSITION
SIR ANYONE THERE'S NO ONE IN
THE GALLERY NOR IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE HERE TO TESTIFY- IN
OPPOSITION. OF META MODERATORS
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE.
TESTIFYING WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU FOR IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO NOW. ONE ZERO FOR ANY
OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION THANK YOU MISTER
ALREADY THANK YOU LET'S BRING
IT BACK TO THE CHAMBER OF
QUESTIONS COMMENTS SENATE
GONZALEZ- CENTER GONZALEZ HERE
THANK YOU- MISTER CHAIR AND I
JUST WANT TO STAND IN STRONG
SOLIDARITY WITH MY COLLEAGUE-
CENTER MAN AS SOMEBODY WHO
REPRESENTS ONE OF THE LARGEST
CAMBODIAN COMMUNITIES OUTSIDE
OF THE COUNTRY OF CAMBODIA AND
LONG BEACH- I JUST WANT TO SAY
HOW. MUCH I'M I'M I'M I'M HURT
AND DISAPPOINTED IN THE ACTIONS
OF THE VERY FEW FOLKS THAT HAVE
PERFORMED AND CONTINUE TO PUSH
THIS DOMESTIC TYPE OF TERRORISM
UTILIZING WHAT THEY CALL IT
SPEECH- AS HATRED ACTS TOWARDS
THE EPA COMMUNITY- IN L. A.
COUNTY COMMISSION ON HUMAN
RELATIONS ALSO FOUND. THAT
WE'VE SEEN IN L. A. COUNTY THE
GROWTH AND A LOT OF THESE
DOMESTIC TERRORIST ACTS TO
TOWARDS THE API COMMUNITY AS
WELL AS OUR MIDDLE EASTERN.
COMMUNITY ARE JEWISH AND TRANS
GENDER COMMUNITIES AND FOR THAT
REASON I WANT TO JUST AGAIN
STAND IN STRONG SOLIDARITY AND-
THANK A SENATOR MEN FOR ALL OF
HIS WORK IN THIS SPACE. THANK
YOU SENATE GONZALEZ- CENTER THE
RUSSELL. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
R. I. REYES ALL TO IN SUPPORT
AND- WHEN APPROPRIATE MOVE THE
BILL- MY DISTRICT SENATE
DISTRICT TWENTY FOUR IS A VERY
BEAUTIFULLY DIVERSE- DISTRICT.
IT INCLUDES- THE API
COMMUNITIES OF KOREATOWN A
HISTORIC FILIPINO TOWN LITTLE
BANGLADESH. CHINATOWN AND
LITTLE TOKYO- THE ARMENIAN
COMMUNITY- IT IS VERY DIVERSE
AND I'M VERY PROUD AND ALSO
CONCERN WHICH IS WHY STAND TO
SUPPORT THE RESOLUTION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO WE
KNOW YOUR MOTION- CENTER LAYER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I ALSO
RISE IN SUPPORT AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE- I SORT
OF LEARNED THE HARD WAY WHEN I
WAS MAYOR OF A TOWN. THAT THE
PUBLIC STANDARD WAS SET AND
MANY TIMES LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
OTHER PEOPLE WOULD ACT ON WHAT
THEY PERCEIVE TO BE THE PUBLIC
STANDARD AND THE PUBLIC
STANDARD IS A STANDING HERE
RIGHT NOW. AND SAYING WE AS A
COMMUNITY BROADER THAN I JUST
ONE PARTICULAR GROUP SAY THAT
THE SAFETY OF EVERYBODY IS ALL
OUR ISSUE AND SO THAT'S WHY I
RIGHTS IN SUPPORT OF THIS I
THINK WE NEED TO MAKE THAT OUR
PUBLIC STANDARD. AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS RESOLUTION DOES I ASK
EVERYBODY TO VOTE ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SIR LAYERED ON NOT
SEEING ANY OTHER MICROPHONES
UP- SENTIMENT THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR BRING THIS RESOLUTION- IT I
THINK IT'S OUR FERVENT HOPE
THAT THOSE COWARDS WHO
PERPETRATE THESE ACTS OF
VIOLENCE AND PROPERTY DAMAGE BE
APPREHENDED. AND BROUGHT TO
JUSTICE I KNOW MY OWN DISTRICT
THERE'S BEEN A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT INCIDENTS INCLUDING
THE DESECRATION OF A NUMBER OF
BUDDHIST TEMPLES WHICH IS- WE-
THAT THAT KIND OF PROPERTY
DAMAGE IT IS- IS ESPECIALLY
EGREGIOUS BECAUSE IT SENDS.
SEVERAL MESSAGES SO I THANK YOU
CENTERMAN SENTIMENT IF YOU CARE
TO CLOSE I JUST WANNA THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR YOUR WORDS OF
SUPPORT FOR THIS RESOLUTION I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE AGAIN THE
IMPORTANCE AS- MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER LEONARD STATED. OF
STANDING UP FOR THESE
COMMUNITIES AT A TIME WHEN WE
ARE FEELING. DOWNTRODDEN AND
TARGETED. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU CENTER MAN ALL RIGHT
MA'AM SECTOR IF YOU'D CALL THE
ROLL EXCUSE ME MA'AM CHIEF
COUNSEL. THIS IS SENATE
RESOLUTION TWELVE. BY SENATOR
MAN WITH THE MOTION BY DID US
SENATOR DID ALSO. THE MOTION IS
BE ADOPTED ORDERED TO THIRD
READING SENATORS PLEASE TURN
YOUR MICROPHONES ON- BURKE. IT
US SO DO HIS LATE EXISTENCE THE
REST SO I GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ
I HERTZBERG. JONES JONES I
LAYERED HOW DID COVER YOUR-
VOTE WE GET. WHERE'D I SET OFF
OF THIRTY FIVE IMPERIAL STERN.
WHY CASKEY ARE WHY CASKEY AYE
WIENER. YOU HAVE EIGHT ZERO
RIGHT NOW HOLD OPEN TICKET WILL
WILL PLACES ON CALL- LAST AND
FINALLY A CENTER WHITE CAL SKI
WITH SB THREE FOUR SIX JUST A
HEADS UP TO THE MEMBERS WHO ARE
NOT PRESENT IS IT THIS IS THE
LAST BILL WE'RE GONNA BE
HEARING TO. SELTZER WHAT
HOUSEKI. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND I'M PLEASED TO BE THE LAST.
BILL PRESENTED TODAY THIS BILL
THREE FOUR. SIX WILL PROTECT
CONSUMER PRIVACY BY REQUIRING
THE CONSUMERS BE INFORMED AT
THE TIME OF PURCHASE IF THE
CAMERA IS INSTALLED IN THE CAR.
IT WILL ALSO FURTHER PROHIBIT
THE VIDEO RECORDINGS ARE MADE
INTO YOUR CAR- BY THIS IN
CAMERA IN VEHICLE CAMERA FROM
BEING USED FOR ADVERTISING OR
SOLD TO THIRD PERSONS. WE SPEND
A GREAT DEAL OF TIME INSIDE A
CAR WHAT WE DO. WHAT WE DO
WHILE DRIVING WHETHER COMMUTING
TO WORK RUNNING ERRANDS PICKING
UP OUR CHILDREN FEELS A GREAT
DEAL ABOUT WHO WE ARE IT'S FOR
THESE REASONS THAT MANY OF YOU
THEIR CARS A SECOND HOME AND
WHY WE HAVE. A REASONABLE
EXPECTATION OF PRIVACY. WELL IN
THEM. YET IT'S FOR THOSE SAME
REASONS THE FIRM'S COVERAGE.
CAR RELATED INFORMATION SO MUCH
SO THAT RECENT REPORTS SHOW
THAT DATA COULD BE VLUED AT
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY BILLION
DOLLARS BY THE YEAR TWENTY
THIRTY THE USE OF IN VEHICLE
CAMERAS STICK. TO MONITOR DAYS
PAGE ATTENTIVENESS AND RECORD
SENSITIVE DATA WELL WE COMMUTE
TO WORK OR PICK UP OUR KIDS
ALLOWS PRIVATE COMPANIES TO
BUILD DETAIL COMPOSITES OF OUR
HABITS. AND USE THAT FOR
TARGETED INFORMATION THIS IS A
FAST DEVELOPING PROBLEM ONE
THAT WILL ONLY GROW MORE
INVASIVE AS TECHNOLOGY
PROGRESSIVE AS WE SIT HERE
TODAY WE KOW THAT BMW HYUNDAI
AND KADLEC HAVE MODELS. ARE IN
CAMP IN CAMERA MODELS. THEY'RE
BEING SOLD THAT ARE MONITORING
THE DRIVERS THING FACIAL
VEHICLE FACIAL RECOGNITION
SOFTWARE ROOM AVAILABLE TO READ
YOUR MOOD BY PROHIBITING
VEHICLE RECORDINGS MADE FROM IN
VEHICLE. CAMERAS FROM BEING
USED FOR ADVERTISING OR SOLD TO
THIRD PARTIES SB THREE FOUR SIX
ADDRESSES THE PROBLEM BY THE
TRUTH AND BEFORE TAKEN BALLOON
OUT OF CONTROL IN WITH ME I
HAVE DANIEL GET TERRORISTS
WHO'S THE LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE
FOR CONSUMER FEDERATION. OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT NITROGEN
EITHER. THANK YOU SO I CASKEY
MR GUTERRES ARE YOU ON THE
PHONE. GOOD AFTERNOON TO
REMEMBER THIS I AM ALREADY OF
THE FLOOR'S YOURS. MY NAME IS
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ANIMAL
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA A NONPROFIT
FOUGHT
PROTECTION. AND PRIVACY
ESPECIALLY ON THE BASIS OF
ADVANCING TECHNOLOGY OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS THE
LEGISLATURE COMPLETING CONSUMER
PRIVACY VERY SERIOUSLY I HAVE
TAKEN ACTION IN SEVERAL AREAS
TO PROTECT CONSUMER DATA.
INCLUDE PROTECTIONS FOR SMART
TV RECORDING AND VEHICLE EVENT
DATA SB THREE FORTY SIX WILL
PUT INTO PLACE MUCH NEEDED
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS IN THE
FACE OF A RAPIDLY EXPANDING NEW
FEATURE IN MANY CARS. YOU'RE
YOU'RE FACING CAMERA KEEP OF
RECORDING THE DRIVER AND
PASSENGERS SEVERAL CAR
MANUFACTURERS LIKE GENERAL
MOTORS AND CHRYSLER ALREADY
INCLUDING CARE FACING CAMERAS.
IN THEIR VEHICLES THANK SEVERAL
OTHERS PLAN TO INCLUDE THEM IN
THE FUTURE. ALEXI P. SIX FOR
EXAMPLE CURRENTLY USING IN
VEHICLE CAMERAS TO RECORD THE
DRIVER DURING ECONOMIST WRITING
SESSION. AND THE TOTAL MODEL
THREE INCLUDE THE CAMERA ABOVE
THE REAR VIEW MIRROR VIDEO
RECORDING SHOULD NOT BE TAKEN
INSIDE A CAR WITHOUT THE
CONSUMER'S KNOWLEDGE. NOR
SHOULD THE VIDEO BE SHARED OR
SOLD OR OTHERWISE DISTRIBUTED
CONSUMER PRIVACY IS A CRITICAL
ISSUE WE SHOULD NOT ALLOW CAR
MANUFACTURERS FIND BETTER
ABILITY TO VIDEO RECORD AND
USED FOR COURT AND- THREE FORTY
SIX BUT THE PLACE COMMONSENSE
PROTECTIONS THE GUARANTEE THAT
THESE KINDS OF VIDEO RECORDINGS
ARE PROTECTED. AND CONTROLLED
EXCLUSIVELY BY THE CAR OWNER.
THE BILL REQUIRED THE CONSUMERS
ARE INFORMED AT THE- POINT OF
PURCHASE THAT THEIR CAR INCLUDE
TWENTY THINKING PEOPLE CAMERA.
THE BILL ALSO PREVENT CAR
MANUFACTURERS FROM SELLING
THESE VIDEOS OR USING THEM FOR
ADVERTISING. AT THE PROBLEMS OF
THE SAME VEHICLE CAMERAS
CONTINUES TO INCREASE THIS BILL
WILL ENSURE THE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS ARE NOT LEFT BEHIND.
EVEN GOING TO US FOR THE
PROTECTION OF EVEN MORE WHITES
INFO AND USE OF THE VIDEO.
LIMITS SET THE PARAMETERS NOW
SO THE CAR MANUFACTURERS ARE ON
NOTICE THE PRIVACY OF OUR
DRIVERS MUST BE TAKEN SERIOUSLY.
HERE ARE STRICTLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU TEARS- LET'S TURN OUT
OF WITNESSES IN THE IN THE US
SENATE CHAMBER I SEE NONE THERE
ARE NONE IN THE GALLERY NEXT
ROOM ONE TWELVE IF WE COULD SEE
ROOM ONE TWELVE THERE ARE NO
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE-
MADAME MODERATOR LET'S TURN TO
THE PHONE LINES NOW IF YOU CARE
TO TESTIFY- IN SUPPORT NOW'S
YOUR OPPORTUNITY SIMPLY
ANNOUNCE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION. AND YOUR
POSITION- MADAME MODERATOR IF
WE COULD GO THE PHONE LINES.
THANK YOU IF YOU WERE IN
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO
NOW. AND SUPPORTED ONE ZERO. WE
HAVE ONE IN THANK YOU NEVER
COME FROM LINE SEVENTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK CATALINAS
DENTURES I WOULD CORPORATE IN
KIND ON BEHALF OF THE PRIVACY
RIGHTS CLEARINGHOUSE AND
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
WELL HERE'S THE ANY OTHER
FACTOR THE SENATE NOT REFLECTED
IN THE ANALYSIS WE ARE ANY
SUPPORT IF AMENDED POSITION. WE
HAVE BEEN IN CONVERSATION WITH
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND
SPONSORS AS TO THE NEED FOR
ENSURING CONSUMER PRIVACY UNDER
THE LAW WITH THE INCLUSION OF A
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION WE
APPRECIATE THE TIME THE AUTHORS
OFFICE HAS GIVEN US AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION THANK YOU. ALREADY
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF THE PHONE LINE. AND
AGAIN IF YOU WERE IN SUPPORT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. IN THE NEXT FIVE WILL
COME FROM WIND TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING SHARE AND-
COMMITTEE THIS IS TRACY
ROSENBERG FROM OAKLAND'S
PRIVACY. AND WE ARE CALLING TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR SENATE
pANYONE ELSE IN Q. AND AGAIN AND.
IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT MY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE NO MORE IN SUPPORT. ALL
RIGHT I THINK WE HAVE MISTER
ANTHONY SAMPSON FROM THE
CALIFORNIA NEW CAR DEALERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION- IS
MISTER SAMPSON ONLINE. YEAH
SURE I'M HERE ALL RIGHT MISTER
SAMPSON YOU MAY GO AHEAD. GREAT
WELL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBER DANTE STAMP THEM
ATTENTION A FIVE ASSEMBLY HAPPY
CALIFORNIA NEW CAR DEALERS
ASSOCIATION. HERE IN OPPOSITION
AND ALL ALL OF THE VERY BRIEF
WITH MY REMARKS BECAUSE- WE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE AND
UNDERSTAND THAT THE POLICY GOAL
OF MAKING DRIVERS AWARE OF THE
PRESENCE OF INTERIOR FACING
CAMERAS. AND CERTAINLY HAVE NO
OBJECTION TO THE UNDERLYING
TEND TO OF WHAT SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE HE- IS TRYING TO DO- WHAT
OUR CONCERNS ARE CONCERNED IT
IS THAT PERTAIN TO THE CONSUMER
BY CONSUMER NOTIFICATION
REQUIREMENT BUT THE ONUS IS ON
THE DEALERS. WITH WITH DOUBLE
PENALTIES ATTACHED AND SO THIS
IS AGAIN A SORT OF A CONSUMER
BY CONSUMER- BURDENS THE
NOTIFICATION REQUIREMENT WHERE
WE'RE HOPING TO- CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THAT SENATOR TO
PERHAPS IDENTIFY SOME
ALTERNATIVE WAYS IN WHICH THE
CONSUMER- CAN BE NOTIFIED AND
BE INFORMED. ABOUT THESE
DEVICES IN THE CAR AGAIN
WITHOUT TAKING THE CONSUMER BY
CONSUMER APPROACH- RESPONSIBLE
BY THE DEALERS FOR EXAMPLE YOU
KNOW THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
MENTIONED AB TWO THIRTEEN FROM
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND THREE
WHICH PROVIDES THAT A
MANUFACTURER OF THE NEW MOTOR
VEHICLES SOLD OR LEASED IN THE
STATE THAT ISEQUIPPED WITH ONE
OR MORE RECORDING DEVICES.
COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS THE
BAND STATE RECORDERS SHALL
DISCLOSE THAT FACT IN THE
OWNER'S MANUAL FOR THE VEHICLE
AND WHILE I'M CERTAINLY NOT-
OPPOSING SORT OF ANY SORT OF
ALTERNATIVE TYPE OF A
NOTIFICATION REQUIREMENT
HEARING COMMITTEE TODAY- WE
WOULD LIKE TO TALK ABOUT THE
PIPES THE POTENTIAL
ALTERNATIVES- TO ENSURE THAT
THE SENATOR- AND THE SPONSORS
CAN ACHIEVE THE UNDERLYING
INTENT WITHOUT- PUTTING THIS
RESPONSIBILITY- ON THE
DEALERSHIPS SO WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE. AGAIN THE SENATORS
GOALS AND OBJECTIVES AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING. THE
DISCUSSION MOVING FORWARD.
THANK YOU MISS SAMPSON- ANYONE
ELSE- MAN RAIDER OTHER OTHERS
ON THE LAW ENOUGH. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE OPPOSITION. YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO NOW FOR
OPPOSITION. AND NO ONE IN OUR
QUEUE FOR UP WITH THIS ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR
AND I NOTED THAT THERE WAS IF I
HAVEN'T ALREADY NOTED NO ONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE NORTH THE
GALLERY- WISHING TO TESTIFY- IF
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE ON THE LINE
META MODERATOR WILL NOW TURN TO
THE- TO THE MEMBERS. FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- ALL
RIGHT- CENTER BOARD JUST GIVE A
QUESTION. GO AHEAD IF I MAY
FIVE IF I COULD POSE SOME
QUESTION TO- THE AUTHOR THROUGH
THE CHAIR THROUGH THE CHAIR. I
REMEMBER WHEN YOU AND I HAVE
TRAVELED TOGETHER AND WE WERE
DEALING WITH- PRIVACY MATTERS-
THE AMERICAN SYSTEM THAT WAS
EMERGING AND THEN FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM IS EMERGING.
IN THE EUROPEAN SYSTEM THAT WAS
EMERGING IN ALL THE ISSUES THAT
WE'VE DEALT WITH IN THE PAST
COUPLE YEARS IN THIS COMMITTEE.
IT'S A TOUGH ISSUE. IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE. AND SO I THINK
BRINGING THIS ISSUE UP I THINK
IT'S HELPFUL. FOR US TO- TAKE A
STAB AT THE NEW DIMENSIONS OF
TECHNOLOGY. AND THE CONCERNS
THAT WE HAVE ABOUT. HOW DATA.
IS USED HOW ARE PRIVATE
INFORMATION. IS COMMODITIZED
AND- PUT INTO THE MARKET- FOR
OTHER PEOPLE TO BENEFIT FROM I
THINK THAT IS BUT THIS IS A
CONCERN OF MINE- SO THIS BILL.
CREATES A PROVISION FOR HAS A
PROVISION THAT CREATES AN
OBLIGATION TO DISCLOSE TO THE
DRIVER THAT HE OR SHE IS BEING
RECORDED- AND THEN YOU CAN JUST
DOCTOR HAD THAT THAT IS
CORRECT. WHAT THREE CHURCHES
DISCLOSED THAT THE CAMERA EXIST
IN THE IN THE- THE CAR- IT SO
IT'S NOT EVERY TIME YOU GET IN
THE CAR IT SAYS YOUR CAMERAS
NOW BEEN ACTIVATED ALREADY
RIGHT USUALLY WHEN ONE LINE
SHUTS ONLY ONCE RIGHT OKAY SO
HERE'S MY CONCERN- I LIKE THE
IDEA THAT AS A CONSUMER. I AM.
THAT SAYS SOMETHING. TESTING
TESTING PER. BUT. THE MALES
STEP AWAY FROM IT.
UNFORTUNATELY CENTER BOARDS I
THINK YOU HAVE TO BE ON THE
MICROPHONE YEAH BUT ITS
RECORDING ME VERY LOUDLY YEAH
IS THAT BETTER OKAY THAT'S
BETTER NOW. ARE- MY CONCERN IS
THAT. THE RECORDING OF
INFORMATION I LIKE THE IDEA
THAT YOU WERE DISALLOWING ITS
USAGE AND PURCHASE BY THIRD
PARTIES I THINK THAT IS VERY
IMPORTANT AS WE LOOK INTO. THE
AGE OF A. I. AND CONSUMER
BEHAVIOR AS WELL AS
INDIVIDUALIZED BEHAVIOR THESE
ARE VERY IMPORTANT THINGS THAT
WE NEED TO PROTECT. YOUR UTMOST
REASONABLY GIVEN THE MARKET
DEMANDS AND THE WAY THAT WE'RE
MOVING FORWARD. WHAT I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT HERE IS. THAT
THIS WOULD BE- DISCOVERABLE
INFORMATION. OUR MEANING THAT
IF THERE WERE ANY FENDER BENDER.
OR ANY ISSUE ON WHETHER OR NOT
THERE WAS- A DISTRACTION OR
INATTENTIVENESS BY DRIVERS THAT
THE DEFAULT POSITION OF EITHER
A PLAINTIFF WORN INSURANCE
COMPANY WOULD BE IMMEDIATELY TO
SEE THE RECORDED INFORMATION. I
DON'T THINK THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL. IS DESIGNED TO DO BUT IT
COULD CREATE A BY PRODUCT THAT
THIS TECHNOLOGY ARE WOULD ALLOW
SO I GUESS MY QUESTION TO YOU
IS. IN CONJUNCTION WITH- NOT
ALLOWING THIS INFORMATION TO BE
DISCLOSED TO THIRD PARTIES.
WOULD YOU BE INTERESTED IN
EXPLORING FOR THE PROCESS MAYBE
NOT JUST THIS MOMENT BUT
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF FINDING
A WAY TO INCORPORATE A
PROVISION THAT THIS INFORMATION
IS NOT DISCOVERABLE IN A CIVIL
CON CONTEXT. SO THAT WAS MY
QUESTION TO ME AUTHOR
RESEARCHER BY MISTER WHAT
KOWSKI I MEAN I'M GOING TO HAVE
TO THINK ABOUT THAT BECAUSE YOU
KNOW WHAT WE WERE. THE HERE
WE'RE FOCUSING ABOUT THE
MONETIZATION STATE ADVERTISING
AND USING THAT TO MAKE MONEY
OFF OF THEM I A- L. IN A CIVIL
ACTION WHERE THERE'S BEEN AN
ACTIVITY I DON'T KNOW- I HAVE
TO THINK THROUGH WHETHER THE
DRIVER. KNOWING THAT THERE'S A
CAMERA IN THEIR CAR WHEN THEY
BOUGHT THE CAR THERE THEY
AGREED THAT THAT THAT THAT
WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT THEY
CAN KEEP OUT FROM THIS
DISCOVERY THE INTERESTING.
INTERESTING THOUGHT I'D IT'S
NOT INCLUDED IN THE CAR IN THE
BILL RIGHT NOW. BUT- FOLLOWED
THINK ABOUT IT IF YOU THAT
THAT'S ALL I MASSIVE YOU COULD
BECAUSE I THINK THERE COULD BE
SOME SERIOUS UNINTENDED.
CONSEQUENCES BY THESE
RECORDINGS THAT YOUR BILL COULD
PREEMPT- AND- IN ADDRESS IT
ADVANCE SO ALL I HAVE TO DO
I'LL BE SUPPORTED TODAY I'M
REALLY HOPEFUL THAT YOU'LL TAKE
THIS UNDER ADVISEMENT AS IS. A
BILL MOVES FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SIR COVER YOUR- IS
YOUR MICROPHONE UP. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANTED TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THIS BILL
I HAD ABSOLUTELY NO IDEA THAT
THIS TALK TECHNOLOGY WAS
AVAILABLE AND THAT IT HAD THE
POTENTIAL TO END UP IN A
VEHICLE THAT I MIGHT PURCHASE
IN THE IN THE FUTURE. I THINK
WE ABSOLUTELY HAVE THE RIGHT TO
KNOW WHEN WE'RE BEING RCORDED
AND THERE'S SOME THERE'S SOME
SITUATIONS WALKING INTO A BANK
WALKING INTO A STATE BUILDING
WHERE YOU KNOW THERE'S CAMERAS
YOU KNOW THAT- YOU'RE YOU'RE
YOU'RE BEING WATCHED BUT TO BUY
A CAR GET IN IT AND DRIVE IN
AND FIND OUT LATER THAT. THERE
HAS THERE HAVE BEEN RECORDINGS
MADE OF YOU INSIDE YOUR CAR
IT'S JUST KIND OF FREAKY AND SO
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
THIS BILL AND I BELIEVE THERE'S
PROBABLY GOING TO BE SOME LEGAL
RAMIFICATIONS THAT WE'RE GONNA
NEED TO KNOW A LITTLE BIT MORE
AND SO I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS THAT ARE MADE. BY THE
GOOD SENATOR FROM FRESNO THAT
WOULD PROBABLY NEED TO LOOK A
LITTLE BIT MORE INTO WHAT CAN
THE RECORDINGS IF THEY'RE IN
THE VEHICLE WHAT CAN THEY BE
USED FOR. BUT JUST KNOWING IS
REALLY IMPORTANT INFORMATION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SO CARILLO ASSERT JONES IS YOUR
MICROPHONE UP THERE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR YET I JUST WANTED
TO KIND OF- WELL FIRST OF ALL.
AGREE THAT THIS IS A PROBLEM
NEEDS TO BE SOLVED I HAVE A
VERY GOOD FRIEND THAT- BUT A
NEW TESLA AND OWNED IT FOR
THREE MONTHS BEFORE HE REALIZES
THE CAMERA IN THE REAR VIEW
MIRROR. AND NEVER COULD FIND
OUT WHAT THE PURPOSE OF THE ACT
AND STILL TODAY DOESN'T KNOW
WHAT THE PURPOSE OF THAT
CAMERAS BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
SERVE ANY FUNCTION IN HIS CAR
THAT HE KNOWS OF- SO I DO THINK
WE NEED TO. LOOK AT THIS THE
PROBLEM I HAVE WITH THE BILL AS
IT'S WRITTEN IS PUTTING THE
RESPONSIBILITY ON THE
DEALERSHIPS WE HAVE PUT SO MANY
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS ON THE
DEALERSHIPS- IN CALIFORNIA- AND
IF THIS WAS A ONE A PROFIT BASE
FOR THE DEALERSHIP I COULD SEE
THE NEXUS OF PUTTING IT ON THEM
BUT I DON'T THINK THAT THE
DEALERS HAVE ACCESS. TO THE
DATA THAT'S BEING SHOULD COULD
BE SHARED. OR BE SOLD. SO I
THINK THAT PUT IT ON THE- ON
DEALERSHIP. I JUST GO THERE
MAYBE YOU WANT TO SPEAK TO THE-
CONCERNS OF THE NEW YORK TO
THAT CONCERN I TAKE I'M KIND OF
ST REDDING WHAT THE- NEW CAR
DEALERS ASSOCIATION SAID- SO
THAT'S KIND OF WHERE I'M AT I'M
I'M- I LIKE THE IDEA. I'M
OPPOSED TO THE BILL AS IT'S
WRITTEN BECAUSE OF THE- PUTTING
IT ON TO THE DEALERSHIPS BUT
THERE'S ANOTHER SOLUTION. I'M
CERTAINLY OPEN TO THAT
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU SIR
JONES I DON'T SEE ANY OTHER
MICROPHONES UP- NOTHING INTO
THE MICROPHONE CENTER WHAT
COUNTS YOU CARE CLOSE MISTER
BASIC ALTON WITH THE SPOILS
DOWNTURN PRIORITIES WHETHER WE
CONSIDER THE EROSION OF OUR
CONSUMER PRIVACY A SIGNIFICANT
ENOUGH ISSUE TO PREVENT IT'S
CHIPPING AWAY BY IN VEHICLE
CAMERAS WHETHER EVERY FEATURE
OFFERED BY INVASIVE
TECHNOLOGIES. IS WORTH THE LOSS
IN PRIVACY THIS BILL THREE FOUR
SIX FALLS IN THE FORMER
CATEGORY. ITS AIM IS TO PROTECT
PROTECT OUR PRIVACY DURING AS
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SALINAS SAID
ONE OF OUR MOST COMMON
ACTIVITIES AND FOR USE REASONS
I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU SO I. CAL SKI- THAT CHIEF
COUNSEL IF YOU CALL THE ROLL
OVER THEIR MOTION. SENATE
CABALLERO MOOSE- THE BILL
BENSHI COUNTS OF YOU CALL THE
ROLL. YES THIS IS SB THREE
FORTY SIX MOTION BY SENATOR
COPY AT ALL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST RE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. UMBERG HI I'M
BURKE AYE BURGESS. BRIDGES BY
CARRIE ADAM. PROBABLY AT ALL I
DID ALSO. THE DALLAS SO I
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE JONES. JONES NO
JON SNOW LAYARD. LAYERED I
STERN. WHY CASKEY. WIECKOWSKI
AYE WIENER. WIENER HI. WHAT
WILL PUT THAT BILL ON CALL FOR
A FEW MOMENTS TO ALLOW SENATORS
STERN OF BELIEVE HE'S THE ONLY
ABSENT MEMBER CAN DO- RETURN TO
THE CHAMBER OTHERWISE AFFECT
BACK CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS
HERE OTHER THAN CALLING- THAN
THAN REVISITING THE BILLS ARE
ON CALL SO MAN CHIEF COUNSEL IF
WE GO BACK START WITH THE
CONSENT CALENDAR YES- ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS ONE TWO
THREE AND FOUR. HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG HI STERN WIENER
WIENER HI THAT'S TEN TWO ZERO
WAITING ON WILL PUT THAT BACK
ON CALL OKAY. EFFORT NEXT FOR
THE SR. TWELVE AT THIS IS
SENATE RESOLUTION TWELVE WITH
THE MOTION BY THE REST OF THE
MOTION IS BE ADOPTED ORDER TO
THIRD READING. HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE STERN. WIENER.
WIENER HI ALL RIGHT- SO WE WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN JUST FOR A
FEW MORE MOMENTS IF WE COULD
HAVE SENATORS STERN- IF HE IS
IN THE BUILDING WE ASK IN
RETURN THE CHAMBER ALL RIGHT.
THAT CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS OF
THE DAY. OTHER THAN THE ROLE
BEING LEFT OPEN FOR A FEW
MOMENTS. THEN CHIEF COUNSEL IF
YOU WOULD OPEN THE ROLE. ONE OF
THE THREE MET OF YES THREE
MEASURES OKAY CAN ON ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS ONE TWO
THREE AND FOUR. STERN. STERN
KERN I THE FOR LIKE THAT OKAY
HELLO STERN AYE STERN AYE THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT- THE LOVE INTO
THEIR OF THE PROGRAM THEY
COUNTERS OUT- ALL RIGHT. NEXT
S. R. TWELVE. THERE'S VERY- THE
SENATE TWELVE OF THE MOTION BY
CENTER GET US TO THE MOTION IS
BE ADOPTED ORDER TO THIRD
READING. STERN NINE STERN I'D
THAT'S ELEVEN TWO ZERO RIGHT
THAT THE MEASURE IS OUT. THE
NEXT SB 346% WHITE CAL SKI IS
AT SENATE BILL THREE FORTY SIX
MUCH BY SENATOR COPIER THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS STERN. BY STERN
AYE THAT'S TEN TO ONE ALL RIGHT
THE BILL IS OUT THAT CONCLUDES
OUR BUSINESS. THANK YOU
EVERYONE. JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
IS ADJOURNED.